[Music]
you're gonna get slimed okay best thing
about mom and that's not mom is watts
she is nice nice nice
she's cool she's always there for you if
you have a problem
yeah the funniest person I know yeah I
think I like kids
yes I like that first of all this
outfits on point and I'm wearing
appropriate underwear underneath because
it is the Kids Choice Awards it's a
onesie at the Kids Choice Awards but it
do me are ones
it's very demure very subtle listen I
don't want to get you in trouble but are
you going to the Royal Wedding I come
answer that the wedding invitations went
out did you see them how are you doing
with spice I heard an animated movie
either robot together we're an animated
superhero movie is there any trick I
want to confirm that but there's a lot
going on
I will we just talked about Madison's
gloves yes tell me about your gloves
girlfriend I don't know really much
about it cuz someone else bought me them
and are very great I love that and your
sparkly like you know situation yeah I
meant Beauty mm she's 9
I can't believe that yeah yeah are you
ready for the Spice Girls to get back
together like I am looking a little
sporty style you face me that way yeah
I'm really excited it's gonna be fun I
mean I can't say much either but I mean
I'm excited Freddie what's gonna happen
you know everything that's going on yeah
she goes and then this is my
stepdaughter Giselle hi are you excited
when the Spice Girls got cheese and
angel ooh baby with your tan result are
you so excited about the Spice Girls
arena to us we are okay guys we've got
to go fabulous great to see you Mel
thank you so much
[Music]
[Applause]